you know that doesn't make up for the
fact that you were asleep at the switch
oh i was totally sitting here
i was totally sitting here going are
there any other match-ups for the
match-up draft and then i heard kristin
go okay go ahead and i'm like all right
mike talk let's go it was my turn
let's get to the week 10 most important
matchups chris you have the trivia
question for me to determine the first
pick all right so when the bengals play
the steelers joe burrow will be the
eighth rookie starting quarterback since
1950 to face an undefeated team in week
10 or later
the previous seven rookie qb's are 1-6
in those games who had the lone win in
2009
against the 14-0 colts
2000 it would have been a rookie in 2009
yeah
2009 i know it's a it's you're gonna
like it's a tough one because it's out
of sight out of mind right now
but when i say it you're gonna go damn
okay that makes sense um
2009 2009. yeah i mean the only
quarterback i can think of it was a
rookie in 2009's matthew stafford surely
there were more
bradford was 2010. i i give up all right
it was the sanchez
nobody stops undefeated seasons better
than the sanchez all right yeah that was
that's a good one and damn talk about
yes you could start you know two years
to yours to start your career going to
the afc championship game
he set the all-time record for road
playoff wins
in his first two seasons he had four
right set the record right in two years
another good example of it's a team
sport it's not always about the
quarterback so all right here's the one
i'm most excited to see this weekend
it's monoi mono time it's freak on freak
it's in your face trash talking it's dk
metcalf and jaylen ramsey yeah i i can't
wait to see that that to me is the best
man-to-man matchup in the game this week
i would think at points
the rams are gonna put him one on one
with dk they've been doing that a little
bit where hey you take him over here and
we're going to do something else over
there and i would encourage the rams to
continue to do that i think they're
really good when they do that type of
stuff and you pay jalen ramsey all that
damn money so have him go do it but
those two guys as physical and freaky as
they are they have both the kind of
in-your-face type of attitude um i'm
excited to see that match up this
weekend let alone it's going to be a
good game too
remember when jaylen ramsey got under aj
green's skin and aj green blew a gasket
remember that jalen ramsay's the best at
it yeah i do yeah i would not recommend
doing it to dk metcalf
just
as
as an expression of you know the best
interests of jalen ramsey's overall
health and well-being i would not
provoke dk metcalf that that would just
be my approach yeah well i don't think i
don't think that's jalen ramsey's
approach i you know i don't think that
registers in his brain so i don't think
he'll back down one inch from dk metcalf
you know i'm always reluctant to go with
a match-up involving people who won't be
on the field at the same time but to me
we talked about it earlier tua vs justin
herbert the quarterback that the
dolphins took versus the quarterback
they could have taken the first apples
to apples brightline comparison and you
know two had downplayed it yesterday as
he likely would and anyone would but
it's unavoidable the dolphins could have
had herbert herbert so far has been
better now in part because we've seen
more of herbert but uh yeah that to me
that's the matchup of the weekend tua
versus herbert for the first time we're
looking for that next peyton manning tom
brady
maybe maybe this is in the conversation
we'll see how it goes the first time
around yeah we'll see i mean either way
both guys have showed they belong to
this point yeah we don't know as much
about tua but yeah it's five and sixth
pick of the nfl draft it's it's pretty
good damn match up and you know like you
said one of them is on fire and awesome
i mean herbert has established that like
i'm a superstar not just a quarterback
that's gonna start for your team a
superstar and we'll see if tua can and
can uh inject himself into that type of
combo convo too i'm gonna go to another
rookie qb because i'm excited to see it
you know it's joe ohio versus pittsburgh
i want to see joe ohio you know joe
super bowl all right joe burrow against
this pittsburgh steelers front seven
this defense in general the bengals have
figured out how they want to play
football on the offensive side
burrow has really
you know has been awesome from the start
but he's even
you know been better here as of late as
far as fine tuning and really smoothing
out his game as far as nfl life's
concerned so
and you know they have an interesting
attack between his abilities and his
abilities to read defenses and their
talent at receiver
and they have a very good quick short
pass game
i think that can make life interesting
against the pittsburgh steelers i think
that's the type of formula where i won't
be shocked if it's you know late in the
fourth quarter and we're going man the
bengals are only down by four the
bengals are only down by seven yeah i
wouldn't and of course he can make some
ham plays off schedule too so i'm
excited to see him in that situation
against that defense and uh how he plays
14 carries for 35 yards that was the
stat line the last time dalvin cook
faced the chicago bears defense at
soldier field cook has been averaging
170 yards rushing per game in the last
four games he played start to finish i
take out the seahawks game because he
exited at halftime with 65 or just just
after half time i want to see cook
against that bear's defense is cook
really at a level where no one's going
to be able to stop him or will a good
defense be able to slow him down chris
that's what i want to see on monday
night no i i'm with you mike this isn't
i had this written down as well i mean
to me it's a fascinating matchup because
yeah it's it's good on good and all that
but two
as this is the kind of team where like
the bears can the bears can beat these
type of teams if they stop your run you
know your vikings pass gaming all that's
special when it's just drop back pass
and do all that so that is going to be
interesting and the bears run defense
you know as you saw last week
statistically for the year i think
they're letting up like 120 yards a game
something like that yeah 120 which is
not like towards the top of football but
you saw last week when they play a team
that's run first they can stop it they
usually don't help their front seven out
they're big and physical and they just
let them go so that'll be cool to watch
all right i'm going against we just had
one thing let me add one thing about the
monday night game yeah
the vikings have been very bad at
soldier field yeah they're fortunate
that fans won't be there and in
particular if you haven't seen the video
go find it on twitter kirk cousins is
very fortunate there won't be fans there
because he would have been serenaded
with pretty woman all night long by the
bears fans check out the video of kirk
cousins singing in high school if you
haven't seen it yet go ahead he's
actually not bad it's just funny to see
no it is it is funny to see and i'm sure
he's hearing about that in the locker
room today when he's singing his duets
and pretty women and all that kind of
thing it's very funny all right i'm
going my boy versus your boy okay
yep my boy blue versus your boy red okay
here we go
we're gonna do it let's make a let's
make a vote or a wager who has more
total yards in this game kyla murray
josh allen
if your guy wins i'll wear a kyler
murray jersey next thursday on the show
if my guy wins you got to wear a josh
allen jersey on the show
how are we going to get a josh allen
jersey where's it going to come from i
got to buy it and send it loser
you're rich okay okay you can afford it
that's fine that's fine fine i'll pay
for it i owe you anyways i'll pay for
you i'll do it i'll do it no no i'll do
it i'll order it and it'll show up yeah
what am i thinking i mean all you have
to do is press a button in the stuff i
know i was looking for a way out you're
right well yeah it sounded like you were
like expecting a new jersey from the
team like are they going to send it to
us deal maybe they'll send us one maybe
they will i'm sure they're listening all
right uh
i'm i'm i'm with you there and i'm
conflicted not that anybody cares about
anyone's fantasy team but i've got two
teams this year i'm eight and one in
each league josh allen is the
quarterback in one kyler murray and the
other so i want both of them to have
huge huge days because i alone care
about my two fantasy teams did i mention
they're both eight and one all right uh
um and it's horrible i feel bad even
saying it but it's i'm excited this is
the first year i'm actually worth a damn
okay uh then talk about it yeah for the
first time in a long time so i'm happy
about it last one for me let's go lamar
jackson against that new england defense
especially if
defensive players are calling out what
the offense is going to do because if
anyone cracks the code
on an offense it's bill belichick and
company so let's see what the patriots
defense overmatched physically can do
against lamar jackson yeah that's
amazing that's going to be amazing and i
don't know how the patriots can stop
them with their lack of big people and
all that i really don't i'll be shocked
if they can stop the ravens run game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports